[Music]
good evening everyone so frédéric ferrer zinc
co-founder of the start-up must have had
nothing originally
there is a project by irt and
saint-exupéry in sofia that I had the
chance to set up  as long
as thales was made available with the aim
of lifting the locks on the artificial
onboard after two to and
very promising initial results, among other things
on a leysin concept which is
still in orbit, we decided
with a colleague from the project to  creating the
start-up took nothing to democratize there
is a mark with companies that
do not have the internal skills
to develop it to enable them
to bring their smart products to market more quickly
thanks to an emergence grant from the abbey
we  are developing a dia architecture
to extract
useful information from multispectral images
in real time so as to process
a maximum of application frameworks
directly on the sensor is
intelligent
in
particular for s  sectors of activity
that correspond to our values such as the tech
rid the bull market more broad
y makes envir
nmental monitoring for unia useful to the plane
occupants and embedded in very
oncrete systems so you will have under
tood it within the framework of the  trust project
ya al hurriya
experience on the c7 which deals with the
empowered mark of links in particular
on the optimization of the models before
their deployment on different
material targets without loss of confidence
which we will measure thanks to specific metrics
which will be developed
as part of the project, therefore, as a
developer of end-to-end dia solutions,
we will follow with
great interest also the other themes
of the project because not everything is essential
to gain the trust of our future
customers and their users film
therefore  we are very proud to be part of this
project and we therefore thank you for
your trust
thank you Frédéric
[Music]